lágrimas dentro de la sala durante el
primer día de juicio por el tiroteo
masivo en una escuela de parte la
florida en el banquillo nicolás cruz de
23 años autor del asesinato de 14
estudiantes y 3 empleados escolares
el acusado en este caso se ha declarado
culpable de 17 cargos de asesinato en
primer grado en un procedimiento
anterior las sentencias apropiadas para
el delito de homicidio en primer grado
ya sea cadena perpetua sin posibilidad
de libertad condicional o muerte
la fiscalía ya pidió que el castigo sea
la pena de muerte por una masacre fría
calculada y premeditada de war
y es más
tres días antes de esta masacre el
acusado en este caso hizo un vídeo con
su teléfono y esto fue lo que dijo
hola mi nombre es big voy a hacer el
próximo tirador escolar de 2018 mi
objetivo es al menos 20 personas con un
ar-15 y algunas rondas trazadoras va a
ser un gran evento y cuando me ven en
las noticias sabrán quién soy todos van
a morir
uruguay
el 14 de febrero de 2018 el joven de
entonces 19 años regresó a la escuela de
secundaria mayor it y stone man douglas
de la que había sido expulsado meses
antes por problemas de conducta y abrió
fuego con un rifle semiautomático
durante casi seis minutos después salió
del edificio sin ser detectado y fue
arrestado poco más tarde caminando por
una calle residencial parlan fue uno de
los tiroteos masivos más mortíferos en
eeuu y nunca antes un tirador masivo en
el país había sobrevivido para enfrentar
los cargos